bientôt on dispose aujourd'hui un faux
pas qui veut dit non on se trouve sur
internet
alors je suis le personnage trouble à
droite je suis plus que ça en fait avec
les sens et on voit très mal l'écran
parce que notre super dur mais vous
allez voir quand la vitre leurs gars là
tu sais que voilà ce que m'avait dit tu
sais que je défonce their s'invite de
deux chansons et l'assiette va être
drôle assez serré si je dois donc je
suis fier je vois je suis moi-même à
muzito
dr alors ça c'est à partir en couille
allez merci oui c'est déjà fini a lancé
sa hache que jean drapeau jean b
des thèses courbatiers bourg et des
nations belga
qqs bloqués samedi à quai au maire du
village est en fête
et
non pas perdre alors oui des gens
abbas a un truc il ya deux partout la
ccr ont comme moi j'ai pas atteint que 3
attendu chinois
[Musique]
un attentat fait à l'infini jusqu'à
turnhout eu facile et de l'eau
joe wright
jahia coup le risque n'était pas
dangereux
il ya égalité
non oui non oui j'suis faute et affiche
nos têtes tu vas dire est clair merdes
passé moi d'acheter les volets bon tu
vas faire ce qu'ils puissent critiquer
l'ex moi je te fuis genre ça fait
bizarre
elle met tout en l'air défunt soit
active le truc
ok alors les gens c'est parti on va
faire un petit skrillex si je trouve une
touche à tout elle est à toi est ce
qu'il est là la lada
non oui oui oui parce tu es français et
je suis dans le vrai tube what's that
are well well as dis ouais je sais pas
si je suis chaud là je t'emmerde
joe mather tu me veux tu as gagné tu as
gagné
les battus des dames la toiture j'ai pas
mis à l'ouvragé rouler d'une serait pas
idiot lancé générés servent en partie
gâché par cette idée depuis je voulais
c'est sur le terrain sera très bientôt
pour un nouveau challenge à témoin du
pit a pâti gare à jessica oh mon dieu
c'est après je vais faire un truc us